I will bring you hope old friend I ask
only one thing to return don't get in my
way
so no particular impetus for this video
just some thoughts I had rattling around
what I did kind of a number of videos or
epics as rapid succession about the
x-men in film and sort of the potential
for what may or may not or what I would
or wouldn't like to see happen in terms
of how to integrate x-men into the MCU
which I think we all kind of know is
kind of inevitable at this point there a
lot of the focus that I had was just
very broad strokes like how do we get
mutants in it I talked a little bit
about Charles Xavier but I've been
thinking lately about magneto and I have
a number of thoughts that I just kind of
want to share about what I think his
place can be a couple of possibilities
and kind of my preference for what I
think I'd like to see done for
introducing magneto into the MCU a lot
of this was spawned by I can't remember
where I saw it I think it was in the
comments section on one of those x-men
videos I did earlier but I can't be
certain of it now somebody brought up
the fact that magneto being a Holocaust
survivor would put him yeah pretty much
in his 90s if not quite they're really
close to it and then it becomes a
question of do we start to strain
credibility or do we start to lose what
you know really makes him such a great
character which is that do you have him
be improbably fit for someone that that
uh the age that a Holocaust survivor
would be even a young one or do you
allow him to be as physically challenged
as someone of that age would be and does
he become less threatening as a result
of that so yeah I thought about this and
I thought of a couple things that could
be done now I'm kind of having this
conversation separate from the the stuff
I talked about before my thoughts on how
to integrate mutants introduce them
explain why they haven't come up yet etc
etc this
kind of a separate conversation from
that I'm really just zooming in on
Magneto as a character now first of all
I do want to say I absolutely agree that
Magneto's origins involving his time in
a concentration camp and surviving the
Holocaust are essential to him as a
character it is a massive piece of what
informs his philosophy his life
decisions his dread and condemnation of
humanity he survived the worst of what
humanity is capable of and that does a
lot to shape his outlook on life in
general and humanity and whether or not
they're worth anything so it really is
truly essential to his makeup so I
figured there's a couple different ways
to go about this I'm kind of building up
to the one that was the idea that I had
that I kind of liked the best
so first there is the possibility that
magneto is in fact already dead could be
from age could be you know a case of
heat actually died some time ago and I
think there's a that I know this sounds
blasphemous because I but we love
magneto and and he's really important
he's a really important figure but I
almost wonder if there's more mileage to
be gained at this point out of having
him serve more as a martyr and a
philosophical figurehead than a
character in his own right and I don't
say that because I don't like Magneto I
love magneto but whenever however the
MCU chooses to tackle x-men it does need
to be done differently from how the Fox
movies did it and in some cases that'll
mean skewing closer to the original
comics and the cases where Fox you know
went more there alway but in the case
where Fox was really true to the comics
maybe that means just going in a
different direction from the original
source material so with the idea that
magneto has already passed on sort of my
notion there is you could have it be a
situation where maybe he already tried
to lead some degree of mutant not
prising which was not only put down
but the people who put it down then
covered it up because they first of all
there III think at this point because
the MCU hasn't introduced mutants you
need to cover up you need to have people
covering up the fact that they even
exist but in addition to that if that
ever became public if his place and what
happened to him and what he tried to do
and his erasure from history as a result
of that it would have a similar
connotation to say a slave rebellion
that was wiped from history by the slave
owners that put it down and eco and his
name and his passion and his hopes for
people like him could definitely be used
as a banner and therefore he as I said
he becomes a martyr for a cause as
opposed to a character in his own right
that's one possibility that could be
done with him and it would retain his
original origins I know it's not
impossible to do some sort of time
displacement or reality bending or some
other way to explain why he could have
been there at the Holocaust but is not
actually physically 90 I kind of touched
on that a little bit but I I don't like
those possibilities and I think it's
just a way it's just an excuse to give
us basically just give us a version of
Ian McKellen again and I love via
McKellen and the part but we we already
have it we kind of need something new so
I don't I don't like any of the cheats
that could be used to just bring him
forward in time and not so that he
doesn't have to be that age whether it's
freezing him like cap or we get reality
or time manipulation as a result of
infinity or or any of that I don't
they're possible they are certainly
possible there there are mechanisms in
the MCU that would allow for that to
happen but I don't love those as ideas
the other one that I hit on and this is
the one that that icon it was like like
him it just has a general notion I
actually kind of tossed it out on
Twitter just to see if I got immediate
bite back on it and I didn't that's not
what I'm indicating which I have way
fewer Twitter followers than I have
subscribers here so we'll see what
happens when I suggest this but
going back to what I said originally
that being a the survivor of genocide is
absolutely vital to Magneto's origin and
establishing his philosophies and his
approach to life I do believe that's
true
does it absolutely have to specifically
be the Holocaust though because the
Holocaust was not the last time that
genocide happened I know it's like the
big major frame of reference for a lot
of people out Western audiences mainly
it is our primary frame of reference
because it's the most Bob first of all
it's got the highest death toll for the
ones we've actually been able to
calculate and it also is the one that
happened last you know chronologically
in sort of our realm you know in the in
the Western world when I say Western
world I mean kind of Europe and North
America that's usually what people mean
when they say that so that is our go-to
point of reference but there have been a
lot there was actually quite a few
incidents of genocides really bad ones
in the 70s so he could have been a
survivor of any number of those places
places like Cambodia Bangladesh East
Timor Burundi these are places that went
through horrific genocides of of people
just certain types of people certain
tribes certain races or whatever just
attempting to be wiped out so this
happened again it happened much more
recently than the 30s and 40s which will
allow you to have a survivor of this
kind of thing but not link it
specifically to to the Holocaust
what magneto needs to have been
witnessed to is to see a group of people
being systematically wiped out for no
reason than certain facts of their birth
which is something they do not have
control over that is what matters and
that doesn't restrict it to the
Holocaust it does allow for other things
and you know having him be around for
things
like that in the 70s depending on how
old you want him to be when it happened
to him that will put him in his 50s 60s
you know around about the age mckellen
was when he started playing the
character in the first place when when
the Fox movies first started coming out
or if you want to go more recent that
than that you want to go even younger
there was what happened in Rwanda in the
early 90s and in that case if you wanted
to go that way you could make him
basically my age and you could have him
be a young upstart and somebody who just
is really pushing for now as opposed to
somebody who's more the sort of elder
statesman of a certain philosophy he
could be the the younger firebrand
version if you really wanted to do
something different and have something
maybe more aligned with in line with
Michael Fassbender than the McKellen
take now there should be if you were
paying attention to the places I'm aimed
something kind of obvious that would be
a change to the character if any of
those were selected as the genocide that
is part of Magneto's origin which is
that he wouldn't be white anymore he
would you know depending on where you
wanted to root it it he would probably
be black or Southeast Asian or you know
these other parts that he would very
clearly not be white I'd like to think
not too many of my own subscribers would
have a huge nice shirt knee-jerk
reaction of don't changes race but even
if you do I'm hoping you're gonna stick
around and hear me out on this because
this would not be a case of your
changing his race just because this
would actually be changing it for not a
case of diversity like it will be
changing it in order to actually
preserve the character because like I
said this genocide has to be a part of
his youth it is essential to him as a
character and let's be honest what makes
more sense a weird convoluted you know
time-displaced
reality whatever or just make him the
victim of a more recent thing and again
I do understand that and the MCU allows
for that but is the actual color
his skin so essential that it's worth
going through that sort of narrative
pretzel maze nonsense in order to retain
it when it's just an easier solution to
have him be the survivor of something
more recent and in a way I think
especially if he is a presence in the in
the Western world whether it's in Europe
or in North America where these movies
are usually set you know I mean it's
Marvel almost everything happens in New
York to have him be the victim of a
genocide that doesn't get nearly the
recognition that the Holocaust does at
least not in this country that would be
one more thing to fuel his anger not
only was he part of a people who were
almost wiped out simply because of a
certain fact of their birth but he would
have additional fuel for that anger
because he would have been part of a
genocide that most Americans maybe heard
about in history once and couldn't tell
you much about if you ask them once I
mean I couldn't I had no notion and that
I had to look up are there instances of
genocide recent enough to to go with
this idea that I had and yeah there are
like I'm frightening Lee way more than I
thought there would have been so don't
think that this is me going I know but I
didn't I didn't know well enough either
and actually the Cambodia one was even
suggested by one of the people who were
replied to my Twitter but I mean
wouldn't that just make even more fuel
make him more angry justify it mores
like I have seen what humanity is
capable of doing and what they're
capable of ignoring because as horrific
as the Holocaust was one thing that has
not and yes I know Holocaust deniers are
a thing but as a society we have done a
heck of a lot to preserve the memory of
what happened but when similar things
have happened in other places we kind of
go oh boy that stinks but glad I don't
live there and that it would be one more
thing that could fuel the fire and let's
be honest I kinda would smile a lot if
there were
people who threw a fit because magneto
was changed to a different color and a
different race but the reason for that
change was actually to preserve an
aspect of his character rather than to
alter it because as long as he's still a
survivor of genocide what have you
actually changed all you've changed his
skin colour like you've made the single
most superficial change and but have
done so in order to preserve the true
essence important aspect of his of his
life and his history so yeah that's kind
of where I land I think when they get to
magneto and introducing him to the MCU I
think he should be the survivor of a
more recent genocide than the Holocaust
I think that would be an interesting
take it'd be a different take it would
retain the character at his core and it
would allow us to avoid any needless
weirdness to try and justify him being
around otherwise and we would still get
to keep him cuz I mean with my initial
idea which they don't hate the idea that
he's already passed on like we would see
his impact and you know we saw that a
little bit with the spider-man home
company that we didn't actually ever get
to meet Uncle Ben but we still see the
impact that he and his death had on
Peter
the difference is though Uncle Ben was
never a character beyond just the
origins of spider-man he was always just
kind of a presence in memory whereas
magneto he could be that but we would be
losing something because he has been a
present
you know vibrant character and it would
be a shame to lose that so yeah I think
I think I'm done so those are my
thoughts on how I think the MCU should
update magneto what are your thoughts on
this whatever they are
keep them civil even if you disagree
with me please but put them down in the
comments let's talk about them don't
forget like subscribe all that stuff I
got links to a bunch of stuff down below
podcasts that I'm involved in my Twitter
all that's in the description and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]